sans promenades a besoin d'une nouvelle race de
criminels nous devons continuer à évoluer
va rester au top nous aurons besoin de plus d'
argent
c'est la centaine de mille même quand
tu viens tu dois faire tellement plus tu
sais que nous connaissons la profession non l'
Albanie ils  ce sont de très gros trafiquants
je mettrai 100 grammes sur leur [ __ ] de route
et je veux le récupérer si tu veux prendre le
relais ils peuvent avoir à travailler avec moi
on est formé ensemble
sergent-détective Logan tu penses que les policiers
comme Michael Logan ne le feraient pas  exister il
existe s'ils font du bon travail qu'ils
viennent toucher environ 30% vous [ __ ] de
blagues de marins interrogeant votre équipage pendant que
nous parlons Michael
donc devenir un peu désordonné ce lot
Michael étiez-vous impliqué vous
vous vengez de moi ouais ces 33 000 Mike
Mike tu me baises
qui a été victime d'intimidation Michael Lewis
il est coupable d'extorsion de corruption
ciao Emma n'a pas été témoin de
tout Mike